we have won the great pool now we will
win the last war
rip her out root and stem we hope to
kind of avoid the expected and Jon Snow
has always been the hero the one who's
in the Savior but it just didn't seem
right to us for this for this moment we
knew it had to be Valyrian steel to the
exact spot where the child of the forest
put the dragon glass blade to create the
night King and he's uncreated by the
Valyrian steel at the end of it it's
it's still it's a it's a victory for the
living but at great cost because some of
our favorite characters fall along the
way hi everyone its Charlie this is
going to be my Game of Thrones Season 8 episode 4 trailer video talking about
the next big Wars Daenerys is calling it
during the trailer the last war there's
still so much stuff going on we've got
the Game of Thrones prequel that's
coming up too so be sure to subscribe to
get all the Game of Thrones videos I
know there are a lot of questions after
last night's episode there are a couple
more bonus videos that I have planned
about that but I'm also doing the Q&A
video and there's a new round of that
HBO now giveaway - all you have to do to
enter that is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on the video obviously careful
for spoilers for everything through
episode 3 so here we go would you start
with the footage so this very Daenerys
and Cersei centric trailer it's all
Daenerys is voice over from a couple
different speeches or maybe just one
speech broken up into a couple different
pieces because there's only one part of
the trailer where you actually see her
speaking the words but it's all about
the aftermath and them sort of cleaning
up the battlefield you see them burning
the bodies in here - it's going to stink to
high heaven around Winterfell until all
those bodies are gone the whole idea
here is Daenerys says is we won the
Great War as they talked about the war
against the knight King in the White
Walkers now we will win the last war and
she's absolutely determined she even
puts herself in a very deep Targaryen
red dress which is interesting because
Cersei is also wearing a very deep red
dress without listening to the costume
designer explain why she made those
choices why those colors in particular
because Targaryens do wear red so it's
not unusual for Daenerys to wear red
dress but it is kind of interesting that
she wears red because it's the colour of
blood even though House Targaryen 'he's
motto is fire and blood right after the
Battle of Winterfell when they shed all
that blood because you basically lost
all of the Dothraki they're still dos
rocky in the East that did not side with
Daenerys and come over this
just her blood riders that she lost but
they're completely gone
they lost most of their forces most of
the unsullied as well usually after
something like that you wear black which
is also a Targaryen color because you're
in mourning for all the people that you
lost like she'd be in mourning for sir
Jorah because she cared about him so
much even though it was an actual
romantic love you see her in the red
dress
toasting everyone in the Great Hall
because they're obviously really excited
that they all survived they finally won
the war now it's time to get ready for
the next one you could draw all kinds of
metaphors about the red wedding Arya's
reverse red wedding all the red blood
that they're going to be shedding during
the last war which it seems like might
be most of episode 5 although I don't
think the battle will be quite as big as
the Battle of Winterfell just in terms
of a production biggest difference in
the next big battle is it'll probably
take place during day time hopefully so
you'll actually be able to see what's
going on and because of that
geographically it'll be much easier to
place yourself where as it seemed like
the Battle of Winterfell was the biggest
that the show had ever done it may have
actually taken place over a much smaller
area because Winterfell even though it's
a huge castle isn't nearly as big as the
red keep in King's Landing
Daenerys says they'll rip Cersei out
root and stem I guess that she's the
root and Euron is the stem because it
seems like you're on is proposing to her
in this trailer and she'll probably wind
up accepting because even if she doesn't
like him that much she still needs his
help so she needs to keep that Alliance
intact so as Stannis Baratheon would say
go ahead do your duty like what he was
talking to Brienne he knew what was
about to happen and even though it
wasn't going to be pleasant he knew that
it had to go down that way sir she's
backed herself into a corner and now
she's doing everything she can to keep
her house of cards from collapsing you
get a really good shot of the smoldering
remains of Winterfell post battle the
next morning like I said they'll
probably reflect this in the opening
credits Cersei and Euron looking down to
the commoners and King's Landing walking
around in the square giving you a really
big look at the front gate that'll be
important for the next big battle
episode like they did for Winterfell
they built all these new King's Landing
sets because they're going to be using them way more than they have in previous
seasons most of their King's Landing
city shots are filmed in and around
Dubrovnik and Croatia but a lot of the
big battle stuff that they're getting
ready to film at King's Landing they
filmed on their Titanic's that they had
to build special sets just because of
what they're doing during the battle we
don't know exactly how the battle is
going to go
down but we do have a broad idea and we
know finally we're going to get to see the
golden company in action
you see Sansa watching the northerners
as they clean up the battlefield and
start to repair the worst damage to
Winterfell it's going to take them a long
time to rebuild Winterfell but it's not
nearly as destroyed as I expected it to
be I knew that some of the castle would
be left but when you saw the night King
used Vissarion to just plow right
through one of the walls towards the end
of the episode I expected a lot more of
that
but this Aryan did spend like the last
at least ten minutes of the episode just
breathing blue flame all over the
courtyard the weird thing about the way
they cut the trailer too is it seems
like everyone is headed down to King's
Landing on Daenerys those ships
eventually but based on the misleading
way that they cut this it seems like
Sansa might not go back to King's
Landing with them which would be
interesting because she did vow a long
time ago never to go back just because
her time with Joffrey with the
Lannisters was so bad she never ever
wanted to return so you guys can let me
know in the comments just assuming that
this trailer is misleading do you think
that Sansa actually will go back to
King's Landing before the end of the
season because remember even though we
have this episode five big battle coming
up we don't know exactly everything
they're going to be doing during the finale
in the finale is going to be one of
their longest episodes ever you see
Daenerys walking around the halls of
Winterfell in that deep red dress you
see regal fly over Daenerys ships as
they're sailing for King's Landing you
also see regal and rogue on flying over
Sansa standing on the battlements of
Winterfell so confirmed to both be alive
and well none the worse for wear and a
lot of people were wondering what
happened to ragle after he and Jon Snow
went down it seemed like he was still
alive and unless you see a body you
can't really say yes or no because there
have been a couple of deaths that
happened off screen some are sacrificed
himself to allow them to get away you
didn't exactly see him die so it seemed
like it happened off screen so I think
everybody was kind of worried especially
until we saw a ghost in this trailer -
very good boy who also shows up outside
that we didn't know whether or not they
killed him off screen - because he ran
to the assault with the Dothraki and
surged or at the beginning of the
episode but you never really saw him
come back so Evan was just kind of
crossing their fingers speaking of which
I don't think that Ghost would be down
for carrion or the Dragons either there
still is food for them to eat up there
and now that they have maybe a fraction
of their troops it's not like they're
going to run out of their food faster they
haven't actually taken a headcount yet
either for those of you that are asking
how many of their troops are left but
you get shots of Sansa Arya
Jon Snow the rest of survivors standing
outside while we're getting that
Daenerys voiceover which is probably
coming from a different scene you see
Daenerys speaking the second part of her
quote though talking about ripping
Cersei out Rudin's stem inside their
planning room there so maybe that whole
speech just comes from this one scene
there's a scene of Daenerys checking on
drogon I love the look on his face it's
almost like he's smiling a big dragon
toothy smile at something but because
Daenerys is looking up in the sky
they're both probably looking at Riggle
and maybe John Andre gul so she's
probably just relieved that both of her
children are still alive there's the
scene of Arya kissing Gendry later that
night it'll be interesting to see now
that the survivors have sort of found
each other and they're starting to clean
things up how much post-battle sex
happens during this episode a lot of you
remember that robert baratheon quote
from season one in the pilot when he
said I have a son you have a daughter -
Ned Stark let's get them together well
you can actually still do that with Arya
and Gentry now depending on how you
think they wind up it'll be funny to see
how Cersei reacts to Gendry if they wind
up in a scene together knowing that one
of Robert's bastards still exists out
there there's a scene of Jon Snow and
Davos riding out the front gate of
Winterfell with Gilly watching behind
them in the courtyard then they end the
trailer with a shot of Cersei Euron in
the mountain outside looking over
something maybe either watching Daenerys
as ships roll in or maybe just watching
the people of King's Landing go about
their business while they plan for the
next big attack but either way the whole
trailer is just meant to give you the
aftermath of the Battle of Winterfell in
the preparation for the battle against
Cersei so like I said I think the actual
battle won't happen till episode 5 but
we'll see Daenerys as ships rolling up
to King's Landing at the end of episode
4 episode 4 is only supposed to be 78
minutes long so it's about 4 minutes
shorter than episode 3 but episode 5 and
the finale episode 6 are both going to
be 80 minutes long so the last couple of
episodes are actually pretty close in
length but those episode links also
include the little intro the episode
recap they attach the beginning of
episodes they do not include the promos
that they attached to the end of the
episodes because if you watch them on
HBO now they'll just roll from the
episode into the bonus feature X and
stuff so it seems like it's all part of
the episode but really it's not I know a
lot of you are still sort of reeling
about the swerves or the seeming swerves
on the prophecies or a high because of
Arya getting the night king during
episode 3 there's actually a video that
I have plan
for that later this week because there
was a very interesting original plan
that George our Martin had for Song of
Ice and Fire before he changed there was
going to be a big time jump so a lot of the
younger characters like Arya Sansa Jon
Snow by the time this step was happening
in A Song of Ice and Fire originally it
was planned that there would be much
much older but he wound up canceling
those plans things went down a little
bit differently but the main players
were largely still the same although a
lot of the plot machination zan
character relationships wound up
changing like originally there was going to
be an aria love triangle with Jon Snow
in Tyrion in the original outline that
he had so just give you an idea for how
different his original plan for Game of
Thrones was there's so much other stuff
happening this week that video probably
won't post til Wednesday or Thursday but
I will also be doing a Q&A video just
like I've done for previous episodes but
when it comes to essaouira hi there are
still a couple of twists that I'm
expecting that could fulfill the
prophecy
just in a way that you're not expecting
like Danny Dave say during that
featurette were is really important for
them not to play to people's
expectations even though that Jon has
been the main hero thus far they didn't
want him to be the one to get the night
king so I will try to address how much
of that I think was part of George RR
Martin's plan that he gave to Dan and
day when they were plotting out the rest
of the series because a lot of the big
beats are based on what Martin told them
and Martin actually even recently did
talk about how much his ending would be
similar to what they're doing on the
show so I'll talk about some of the
differences that he discussed in some of
the similarities because you will be
surprised by how much of it will be
similar to the way the dream of spring
in winds of winter are supposed to go
down but a lot of the big differences -
especially thematic differences by the
end of the finale we'll be talking about
after we get episode 6 but if there are
any big videos that you guys want me to
do about all this let me know in the
comments congratulations to the last big
giveaway winner Bruno Kerr Honi please
email me on the about page of my channel
so I can get your details while you wait
for everything click here for my episode
3 video and click here for my episode 2
video thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight!